[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
what's up people of the internet i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message i am back in studio after
a week in the great state of florida
it's november 8th 2021 and i'm in the
mood to be here i just had a great
freaking
week before i tell you about my great
freaking week as always you can chat
live during the show
my assistant helen is in the chat right
now over at rubinreport.org
she's looking at your comments she's
sending michael who's sitting right
there questions and comments throughout
the show that i might just read live on
air as always now we are live streaming
on rumble we're live streaming on the
youtube and we are live streaming of
course on blaze tv and yeah i just
had an absolutely great i think it was
eight days
in florida i was up in orlando for a
couple days at the national conservatism
conference if you haven't seen some of
the interviews that i did i sat down
with jack posobiec and chris ruffo and
liz wheeler i saw ted cruz
it was just wonderful i gave a couple
talks i did a little vip
impromptu speech right at the beginning
of the event which that we did post on
youtube already so you can check that
out and then i gave my my big speech on
the on the closing day and then out of
nowhere we were able to pull it together
you guys know jonathan isaac the nba
player on the orlando magic who has come
out against vaccine mandates not against
vaccines uh he has had covet he believes
in natural immunity and antibodies and
herd immunity and things of that nature
and health and being young and eating
right and exercising
i've been in touch with him for the last
couple weeks and i was able to grab him
because he plays for the orlando magic
and the event was in orlando
and we did a quick interview i'd say it
was about 20 25 minutes at the final
dinner of the event we are getting the
video which we will post it was just
spectacular this guy i think he's 22
years old can we check on jonathan isaac
22 or so he is so smart wise kind decent
doesn't want to be out there talking
about this stuff but has stepped into
the limelight and it's just so great you
know i've had the the privilege of uh
privilege and a true sense of privilege
not the way the left uses privilege
privilege of sitting down with some
people who just sort of fall into
something and then like become who
they're supposed to be and this guy is
just absolutely one of those people he's
24 years old he's the wise old age of
24. so we'll get that up for you soon in
florida let me just say it was so
absolutely wonderful of course the
weather is great but it basically is as
if covid does not exist there there's
pretty much nobody in masks everybody's
living their life every restaurant we
went to was absolutely packed every
beach just wandering around taking the
city in occasionally you'd see a mass
person you'd be like oh there's
something wrong with them like it's the
complete flip of what i'm living through
here in la at least for now uh you know
what i'm saying like it's here it's like
everybody's messing if you see a
non-masked person you're like oh i'm
with you are you all right but there it
was just like everybody was just out
things were packed and normal and if you
weren't scrolling on twitter you
wouldn't even know that this pandemic or
whatever they want to call it at this
point even exists anymore and then final
thought i get back here
and the first news i hear is that gavin
newsom you know i don't like this guy
this walking evil disney cartoon villain
he apparently got the covid vaccine or
he got his booster shot on october 27th
and he has not been seen in public since
for 11 days he has just gone completely
m.i.a no one knows where he is now a
normal person if if you know being a
politician was a regular job if you just
didn't show up for your job for 11 days
people might start asking questions i'm
sort of happy about this like i don't
think we need this guy around so who
knows where he is
i don't wish him ill despite the ill
that he has he has thrust on everyone
here in california um but it is a little
weird we haven't heard from him in 11
days since the booster shot and then
someone mentioned to me this morning
that uh jen saki the white house press
secretary jensaki you know her we've
talked about her a little bit uh that
she announced she had coped about a week
ago also vaccinated of course and she's
been m.i.a no one's heard from her uh in
about a week so i don't know what's
going on just uh just just giving you
little bites of information and you can
do what you wish with them uh we got a
bunch of stuff that i want to get to on
the show today first off i'm sure most
of you have seen it already but big bird
has come out for vaccine mandates
basically he's a muppet and then the
puppet joe biden who's in the white
house they started tweeting back and
forth at each other so we'll get into
that and then some stuff just related to
kids and we got some crazy video out of
china about what they're doing with kids
and mandates and it's coming here people
because everyone's just folding like a
paper bag except for specific states in
the united states florida you are one of
them
uh covid vaccines we're going to talk
about that and masks and the cdc people
all that stuff and then finally so it's
three stories basically today this guy
michael eric dyson we've shown you a
little video of him over time he's a
guest on msnbc a lot and he went on like
a completely insane racist rant and the
only place that we
accept racism in america is when it
comes from the left and it's usually
being pushed out there by msnbc this
guy's on bill maher's show a lot and he
just went on this crazy racist rant and
then it reminded uh michael of a video
that this guy did about two years ago he
did a monk debate uh with my friend
jordan peterson where he called jordan
peterson a mean old white man i believe
that was the exact quote so we're going
to show you that we're going to show you
we're going to basically show it to you
and then say to you
who do you think the racist is you'll
let me know before we get to any of that
guys man i really i'm in the mood to be
here today i am in the mood to be here i
always am but like i'm particularly in
the mood to be here today is that
florida's that sun and that air man
it's it's a little moist you can kind of
taste it and the coffee's good down
there had some amazing cuban coffee and
the food oh i'll just say one other
thing about the food so i don't really
go out to restaurants here at la i
basically i i i'm sort of hunkered down
in my bunker here i don't go out that
often
and we host a lot of people and that
sort of thing
but we went out to dinner a couple times
took my team out
went out with some of the locals guys
and everything went to uh houston's
restaurant which you might know as
hillstone some of them were called
hillstone some of them were called
houston's which is really like one of
the greatest chains that we've got in
america like i know people make fun of
like restaurant chains somehow that
that's not good but houston's they not
only is the food great the service great
everything about the restaurant this is
not an endorsement or an advertisement
or anything like that well it's an
endorsement but it's not an
advertisement but just to see a place
that like everything was working
like just to see a place where workers
were happy and they let the workers if
you wanted to wear a mask where i'm
asking you don't don't like just to see
a place where the service was great the
food was great it was packed the
atmosphere was great people were smiling
it doesn't take much man it doesn't take
much uh all right before we get to any
of that i want to talk to you guys about
black rifle coffee i've got the mug
right here uh you know they are not the
typical coffee coffee company black
rifle coffee company develops their
explosive roast profiles with the same
mission focus they learned as military
members serving this great country and
with every purchase you make they give
back black rifle imports high quality
coffee beans from colombia and brazil
and roast five days a week at their
facilities in manchester tennessee and
salt lake city utah black rifle coffee
donated over 150 000 pounds of coffee
that's over 6 million cups to soldiers
deployed overseas law enforcement
officers wildland firefighters on the
west coast and medical workers during
the coven 19 response just in 2020 alone
for every coffee purchase you make
through the month of november black
rifle will send a bag of their limited
edition holiday 30 presence out roast to
a service member currently deployed
overseas to be delivered by christmas
morning being founded and operated by
veterans the team at black rifle coffee
knows what a quality cup of coffee means
to active duty troops spending the
holidays away from home want to support
the cause go to blackriflecoffee.com
reuben today and check out the freshest
coffee in america blackriflecoffee.com
slash ruben and get 20 off your coffee
apparel and gear as well as 20 off your
first month of the coffee club purchase
blackriflecoffee.com
ruben and use code ruben for 20
off uh your purchase including your
first coffee club order that's
blackriflecoffee.com
reuben and now back to me i think i'm
going to have a sip of delicious coffee
after i said the word coffee 87 times
right there
okay so here's the story people they're
coming for your kids now right like it
was one thing they came for all the
adults everyone got injected then got
double injected now booster injected and
you'll get 87 other injections and then
suddenly they'll tell you things don't
work the way they're supposed to work
and oh sure maybe you're going blind or
your heart's enlarged or blah blah blah
but you're going to keep doing it if
you've gone down this path to them
because they're the good guys and they
care about you well now they're really
coming for your kids and we've got a
couple videos here that are just going
to blow your mind here's big
bird
talking about
kovid is from my covenant vaccine my
mommy and my puppy took me to get it
this morning
oh rosita that's great getting the coba
vaccine is a great way to stay healthy
see my mommy and my puppy said that it
will help keep me
my friends my neighbors my abuela all
healthy your parents are absolutely
right you know covid vaccines are now
available for children
five years and older and the more people
who get them the better we're going to
be able to help stop the spread of covid
and keep everyone healthy
okay so the main muppet that you saw
there was cnn sanjay gupta who of course
got owned by joe rogan just a couple
weeks ago we played that video for you
he also played a doctor
known as sanjay gupta in the movie
contagion where he was pushing an
imaginary drug called ribavaron we've
shown you that clip as well uh sorry big
bird himself did not actually
speak there we're gonna get to the big
bird tweet in a moment i don't know who
those other two characters are there but
for the green one who was concerned
about i don't know if that was a boy or
a girl was that a boy or a girl or i
guess it's just a genderless hairy
muppet with some weirdo's hand up but um
that was uh his abuela or her abuela if
the vaccines work then your abuela
wouldn't need you to get vaccinated too
you green freak um anyway let's talk
about big bird because even though i
don't know that red one was that elmo
that wasn't elmo was it or it wasn't
elmo and the green one i don't know been
a little out of the sesame street game
you'll have to pardon me but anyway
putting those people uh creatures aside
a big bird who is verified on twitter
okay i did not know that birds could be
verified on twitter he tweeted this
it's just so perfect i got the covid 19
vaccine today my wing is feeling a
little sore but it'll give my body an
extra protective boost that keeps me and
others healthy miss erica hill even said
i've been getting vaccines since i was a
little bird i had no idea and then that
tweet was followed up by our puppet in
chief joe biden who said good on you big
bird getting vaccinated is the best way
to keep your whole neighborhood safe now
of course let me first say something
which is that big bird is not a real
bird that's talking that's huge big bird
is the product of a sorry connor i
freaked out on that one i just he just
you should have seen me i'm sorry about
that you know
santa claus doesn't exist either you
know it's a lot uh big bird is a
construct made at this point by pbs at
one time jim henson who's long gone uh
that promotes leftist ideology right so
there were a lot of conservatives or
right-leaning people on twitter that
were attacking big bird over this and
then i saw the lefties going see they're
afraid of a big bird they're afraid of a
little children's bird and it's like no
nobody's afraid of big bird or the
weirdo who lives in big bird's outfit or
any of that stuff nobody's afraid of
that but when you're indoctrinating
children to think that they must be
injected with this thing which as we
talked about two weeks ago the fda panel
that just approved the vaccines for five
to 11 year olds they actually said one
of the 17 board members said we don't
know what this is going to do to the
kids we got to inject them and then
we'll figure it out
it's not that anyone's being triggered
or needs a safe space because of big
bird it's that big bird and sesame
street represent giant money
and interest that mostly happen to be
leftist democrat inject you with
whatever we want to eject you with
interests so that is the uh that is the
issue with big bird i am not making this
about big bird himself the character of
big bird they are using big bird as a
proxy for their authoritarian lunacy
okay and then of course joe biden
responding to that i mean it's just so
stupid it's like do you think there is
any chance like even a one percent
chance that they let joe biden tweet
like there is zero percent chance they
do not let joe biden tweet so it's all
just this game it's this k fave which
i've talked about that phrase before
k-a-y-f-a-b-e
this idea that we can present a fake
reality and you'll have real reactions
to it much like professional wrestling
it's this non-stop k-fade we get this
ridiculous children's cartoon character
muppet
to base is big bird technically a muppet
i mean the muppets you know that was you
got your kermit you got your miss piggy
uh gonzo but then then you got the
sesame street but i guess they're all
still they're a type of muppet i suppose
but anyway you've got your muppet and
your puppet and they're just going back
and forth for the rest of us to watch on
all of this and also the more that they
tell
these kids that they have to get the
vaccine so they don't get abuela sick is
also basically telling these kids the
vaccines don't work because if the
vaccines worked and abuela took the
vaccine then abuela would be bueno even
if you were sicko you get it so they're
just absolutely ridiculous but this is
just the beginning this is just the
beginning because china is really
pushing a lot of this stuff it may well
be that the lab leak from wuhan was was
intentional by the chinese we don't know
i actually don't know i won't pretend to
know but i think we should at least be
asking those questions as rand paul and
others have uh but basically all the
countries the western countries in the
world seem to becoming a little more
like china these days we're a little
more authoritarian aren't we so perhaps
china got us to fall on our own sword
and do all sorts of weird things to
ourself well look what's going on in
china right now these are kindergartners
with qr codes hung around their necks in
queue
for covid testing
[Music]
all right so i don't know what they were
saying right there i don't speak chinese
obviously it doesn't even matter that
was video from the post-millennial like
if that's not disturbing to you that we
are turning children into little robots
we are injecting them with things who
would that are not fully tested by
people who would gladly keep you masked
forever and locked in your house and
everything else it's like this this
ain't good and we're kind of becoming
more like china than say china is
becoming more like us right i think i
talked a little bit about this with
blake masters a couple weeks ago who's
running for uh senate in arizona and he
talked about how we got involved with
china in the last 10 20 years thinking
that we could westernize them that we
could bring them the ideas of liberalism
and that that it would help them open
their society but it's actually worked
backwards we seem to be becoming more
like china than they seem to becoming
more like us but again this is coming
for the kids you know right now they
want to inject five to 11 year olds
they're going to be doing this in all
sorts of blue states and we'll see what
happens with the red states
and i don't know i mean i really i'd
love to hear actually if some of you are
parents in the reuben report community
and you're watching this right now
and any of you can join us at
rubinreport.locals.com in the chat i
would love to hear some of your thoughts
on this if you live in a state that's
going to force you to inject your kids
like why aren't you leaving and i get
what a horrific decision that is you
have roots you have a family you have
you have how a house and a career and
all of those things but like when
they're literally coming for your kids
you know when they're saying to you we
don't know why we're doing this and the
vaccines i guess don't really work but
we're going to inject your kids with the
stuff like
maybe you got to move you got to get out
like what else can they take from you if
if they can take your own capacity over
your children's health it really does
make you wonder all right let's talk to
you guys about ladders real quick you
know i want to talk for just a minute
about the things that have fundamentally
changed the way we live these things are
the disruptors things like smartphones
streaming services or dogs named clyde
who like to jump on you each time you
come home he bawled me yesterday another
disrupter i heard of recently is a
company called ladder who basically took
the life insurance industry flipped it
upside down and shook out the
inefficiencies before ladder if you
wanted to get life insurance you had to
sit and drive sorry you had to drive
across town
sit through a sales pitch fill out a ton
of paperwork and then wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you've been
approved you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
your life insurance with things like car
insurance now with ladder you can get
fast affordable term life insurance
without leaving home it's 100 digital
when you apply for 3 million or less in
coverage no doctors no needles no
paperwork so if you're between 20 and 60
need coverage and want to team up with a
company that's redeeming life insurance
choose the ladder the process is super
quick and easy go to ladderlife.com
reuben today and see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
reuben ladderlife.com ruben and now back
to me okay so there's plenty more
related to this covid situation and i
was debating this morning like how much
stuff did i want to do
about kovid because the news seems to be
just like completely littered with it
again even though for the most part
people are trying to just move on with
their lives but this is one of the
issues that we're going to have to deal
with in the world going forward no
matter how much
a certain set of us i think the majority
of us want to move forward with our
lives want to make choices for ourselves
we want to just get
out of this non-stop
awful feeling that we're in with covet
and government uh government overreach
on our lives they're just going to keep
coming so i felt like we had to cover
some of this stuff um so here's a video
of our surgeon general now this is our
same surgeon general who you may
remember two weeks ago said that rachel
levine was the first female four-star
general whatever the hell it is that she
is but of course she's not a female
she does not have ovaries she is a
biological male who's living as a trans
woman that's just fine right that's just
great more power to her but he called
her a female so i'm a little already
i've got a little red flag
about his decision-making process well
here's the surgeon general talking about
federal vaccine mandates now for small
businesses not just those hundred plus
businesses the small businesses as well
dr murphy if the law survives legal
challenges will the administration be
extending the mandate to smaller
employers with fewer than 100 employers
employees
well martha certainly nothing is off the
table at this moment but the focus right
now is on implementing uh the current
rule that osha put out
nothing's off the table nothing's off
the table we could nuke half the country
we could just do anything nothing is off
the table with these freaks that don't
listen to us no matter how many times we
get everything wrong i don't like this
guy i don't think he's very good at his
job i don't think he's honest or decent
and i don't think he cares about
individual liberty i don't think he
cares about the constitution or anything
else i just want to be very clear i've
got michael here i've got connor here
guys i will never force you to be
injected with anything and if i did
force my employees to be injected with
something to work for me i would not be
a good person right i don't know all of
their health habits do you guys both
brush your teeth you both brush your
teeth this morning right we've never had
breath issues around here uh or i don't
know how much deodorant they put on i
don't know exactly when they go to the
gym or whatever and it's none of my
business if they started not brushing
their teeth and never exercising and
they started smelling and whatever then
i might say them we got a problem here
guys we're in a small studio you smell
like we got an issue but i what business
would it be i am a small business owner
right i have a bunch of employees a
bunch of full-timers a bunch of
part-timers we're growing actually we're
going to be hiring more people like
there's a lot of good stuff going on
here imagine how insane it would be if i
as an employer of just it's a job like
this is a job you guys know you're not
slaves right you are free to go did you
know that you could walk out that door
right now i'm not kidding i'm not
kidding
um i don't own these people like they're
allowed to make medical decisions for
themselves but the government is has
become the federal government of the
united states has become the most
psychotic evil totalitarian regime that
that would be almost possible now i i
say that with some hesitation because i
do believe these people can get worse
right like of course they can get worse
they always double down and get worse
but the idea that they would push not
only these big companies okay so fine me
first of all i don't think this but i
could see how someone could make an arm
all these big companies there's so many
people there and you've got to vaccinate
okay fine but little companies with
people that are making decisions for
themselves like will you guys make a
commitment if you're if you're vomiting
say in the morning would you perhaps not
come in you'd be okay with that and if
you were puking your brains out he still
wants to come to work but because these
are good workers that i have here you
see but the point is
i don't have dominion over these people
and i promise you guys i will never
force anyone to make any medical
decision to work for me you know if
either one of you came in and you were
pregnant whatever it might be it's none
of my business
it's fine that's just how it is all
right
um but i won't you know if you start
becoming real fat then i gotta get rid
of you because that i can't have we're
in a small room here it's enough enough
uh all right so if that isn't enough
just like these ridiculous ridiculous
people uh new jersey new jersey governor
murphy this is the democrat who just got
reelected by a hare he almost got uh
taken out a couple days ago in the
election like he just they just missed
it there and new jersey has made their
decision they want to go blue stupid um
so now they've got this guy he's on with
george stephanopoulos talking about when
uh we could maybe take masks off kids
and yeah you're not gonna like the
answer fatigue everybody has it i think
you know it probably people that abide
by the rules have it uh
considering that that seemed to be a
little bit of a motivator for some are
you at all
thinking about
some relief on any of your mandates
listen there's mandate fatigue
everywhere including with yours truly so
let there be no doubt about that
at the moment no but my my hope
is particularly with our kids under the
age of 12 that now being able to get the
vaccine that we will at some day sooner
than later be able to lift the mask
mandate that we have in schools
that is my fervent hope we're not there
yet uh but please god we can get there
sooner than later we got to get there
safely responsibly but i believe we can
get there and i hope it's sooner than
later
it's just perfect he's the perfect
democrat because he's exactly like
fouchy he just says nothing using a lot
of words he hopes we can get there
you know maybe we can get there one day
notice he never gives you numbers we'd
need to see this number so we could do
this even if any of this made sense and
we know that masks don't even make sense
in the first place but congratulations
jersey you voted this guy in so inject
your kids and keep them in masks forever
and by the way the winter's coming and
then they'll tell you oh no
you know we've even got some flu coming
in so we better keep the mass because of
the flu
we'll have more on that in just a second
um but it's just like why are you giving
these people power why are you paying
attention to these people i'm hungover
from florida i'm hungover on freedom
right now i saw the promised land i've
been to the promised land in the
everglades
now we've got cdc director rochelle
wilinski this piece of work and now she
just wants masks forever i'm guessing
she's got some money in a mass company
take a look
[Music]
the evidence is clear
mass can help prevent the spread of
covet 19 by reducing your chance of
infection by more than 80 percent
whether it's an infection from the flu
from the coronavirus or even just the
common cold
in combination with other steps like
getting your vaccination hand washing
and keeping physical distance wearing
your mask is an important step you can
take to keep us all healthy
get vaccine fix
we can do this
oh blow it out your ass lady i just
can't is that a phrase did i just make
up that phrase i don't even know if
that's a phrase i i can't deal with
these people anymore because what she's
saying there is masks reduce the chance
you're going to get sick by 80 but she
said from covid flu and even the common
cold well yes people get the common cold
we've been getting the common cold for
thousands of years people have been
getting the flu for a long time and
usually they survive and you know who
really often survives these things kids
but they want to inject the kids and all
of that nonsense and it's like do you
see the mission creep here this is what
we would call mission creep you go
mission creep usually is thought of as a
military phrase you know you go to war
for one reason we want to liberate these
people next thing you know it's 20 years
later and joe biden you know took the
whole uh us military out of afghanistan
a lot of dead people we left the whole
army there and you know weapons and
everything else like mission creep is
just you have an original intention and
then it becomes something else so i
don't know what the deal is with her
like i'm tired of saying that these
people's intentions are good but if you
think she's wearing masks privately and
if you think that that fool murphy up in
jersey is wearing masks privately there
was a video we played it months ago with
murphy when he was telling everyone to
mask up and he got caught at a
restaurant with his family without masks
and it was just great that video we
should maybe we'll play it for tomorrow
this like perfect like quintessential
like carmine carmela lady from the
sopranos just walks up them and she's
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] mother oh i can't curse damn
well we just got demonetized i've
enjoyed the cash um but she's basically
like the perfect like italian jersey
bomb just like you know you're locking
all our kids away and here you are
eating at the restaurant
anyway with all of that being said i
thought dave this is a dark place we're
going to the sunken place we're going to
depress people is there anyone out there
that's sane could there be a governor of
a state that's doing it right who wants
to free the people q desantis
a year and a half ago we started with 15
days
to slow the spread and now it's gone to
get jabbed or lose your job and today's
osha rule uh very long time coming we
were we were waiting for it that was
issued if you look at it uh here it is
it's almost 500 pages and so we're
supposed to be a government of laws not
a government of men this is 500 pages of
a government of a bureaucracy a
government that is being run by
executive edict not in accordance with
the typical constitutional processes and
the state of florida is going to respond
and we will combat the osha rule as soon
as it's published the state of florida
will be joining with georgia and alabama
as well as private plaintiffs to file
suit
this is a rule that is not consistent
with the constitution and is not legally
authorized through congressional statute
isn't it refreshing to hear sanity it
really is like we live in such an insane
time then when someone comes out there
and says you know we're gonna have to
look at stuff and i don't want to rule
over you and i'm not a king and you know
we've had this mission creep and they
told you one thing but now they want
something else etcetera etcetera and he
says it calmly and thoughtfully uh it's
it's just so deeply refreshing you guys
know i was at this dinner with desantis
uh two three weeks ago sat
next to him for about three hours at the
table guy gets it he's a good
decent man help us ron desantis you're
our only hope so that was just
refreshing so i wanted to end with that
and we got one more one more story for
you today so one of the things i've been
talking about for quite some time is
that the only place that there's real
racism left in america
is on the left right like of course
there are individual racist people there
there are bad people it's just how it is
there are mean people there are people
who do not like black people there are
people who don't like jews there are
people who don't like white people there
are people who don't like gays there are
people who don't like straights but the
only place in america that any of this
is okay and not only okay but actually
manufactured and then pushed out via
giant corporations
is on the left so msnbc pedals in this
social justice nonsense all the time
they constantly attack white people
constantly attack christians constantly
attack straight people it's what the the
network is doing now you may wonder why
would nbc a giant corporation be just
pushing racism all day long but that is
the the path that i suppose msnbc has
decided is right in terms of making
money because at the end of the day
these guys just want to make money so
michael eric dyson who is a professor
who has been on uh bill maher's show
probably two dozen times um
he
was on joy reads show
now you know joy reid this woman is not
well um if you pretend you're watching
her show from a mental institution it
makes a hell of a lot more sense uh he
was on joyride's show and he was
attacking winsome sears now who is
winsome sears well of course as you guys
know last week uh glenn younkin won the
virginia governor's race over terry
mcauliffe terry mcauliffe was the
democrat who said that parents shouldn't
have anything to do with their kids
education critical race theory isn't in
schools you're all a bunch of racist
blah blah blah just a bad dude so
finally we got that hope right i'm
always talking about the hope in the
distance and we got some hope by yonkin
winning absolutely well winsome sears is
the lieutenant governor-elect now she
happens to be a black woman now you
would think that michael eric dyson and
joy reid and the people over at msnbc
who are always talking about systemic
racism might be happy when a black woman
becomes so successful but they're not
into it here's michael eric dyson
problem is here they want they want
white supremacy by ventriloquist effect
there is a black mouth moving but a
white idea through the running on the
runway of the tongue of a figure who
justifies and legitimates of the white
supremacist practices we know that we
can internalize in our own minds in our
own subconscious and our own bodies the
very principles that are undoing us so
to have a black face uh speaking in
behalf of a white supremacist legacy is
nothing new and it is to the chagrin of
those of us who study race that the
white folk on the other side and the
right wingers on the other side don't
understand this is politics 101 and this
is race not even one-on-one what's
beneath one-on-one it's the it's the
pre-k of race you should understand the
fact that if you tell black people look
i support a negro look there is a person
of color that i am in favor of and that
person of color happens to undermine and
undercut and subvert the very principles
about which we are concerned you do
yourself no service by pointing to them
as an example of your racial
progressivism
god there's an awful lot there first off
i just want to reiterate you will not
find anything nearly that racist on fox
news today
or on newsmax tomorrow or any of those
right-wing media outlets that these
people are always freaking out about
that was abject pure racism not reverse
racism not special racism it was just
old-fashioned racism he thinks that this
black woman wins some sears who has a
pretty pretty fantastic resume and and
if you watch some of her talk on the on
election night like this woman's pretty
spectacular okay and i don't care about
the color of her skin these people
racialize everything and then we have to
unfortunately respond to it his line
there a black mouth moving
but white idea running on the runway
like how disgusting is that ideas don't
have color you're allowed to be whatever
color you are and have different ideas
but he thinks that the color of his skin
is the totality of his ideas and that is
so dangerous it is actually racism it is
the very definition of prejudice which
is to prejudge so if you just saw a
black person walking down the street and
you judge them as if i must know all of
the things you think because you're
black that would be prejudice right so
the more that black people succeed the
more that these race hucksters and
that's what they are the more they will
get angry but this guy michael eric
dyson has been doing this for years and
years and years and as i said he's on
bill maher's show all the time he was
actually on this friday and i'll get to
that in just a second but michael
reminded me that he actually did a
debate with jordan peterson this is
about two and a half years ago a little
bit before covet i think maybe i was on
tour with jordan at the time if i'm not
mistaken about two and a half years ago
and they were debating uh race and a
whole bunch of other stuff you know all
the all the stuff that we always talk
about on this show these are the monk
debates and here's michael eric dyson
and then listen to jordan peterson's
response but that is to be complicit in
the very problem itself terminologically
you're beginning at a point this that's
already uh productive and controversial
you're saying how can he get his
equality back who are you talking about
jordan peterson trending number one on
twitter
jordan peterson with an international
international bestseller
i want him to tweet something out about
me and my book
jordan peterson right this is what i'm
saying to you why the rage bruh
you you're doing well but you're a mean
mad white man and you're gonna get us
right
and
well
what i derived from that
series of rebuttals let's say is twofold
the first is that
saying that the radical left goes too
far when they engage in violence is not
a sufficient
response by any stretch of the
imagination because there are sets of
ideas in radical leftist thinking that
led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea not at the level of violent action
it's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence it's like being
against poverty it's like you know
generically speaking decent people are
against
poverty and violence doesn't address the
issue in the least
and with regards to my privilege or lack
thereof i mean i'm not making the case
that i haven't had advantages in my life
and disadvantages in my life like most
people you don't know anything about my
background or where i came from it
doesn't matter to you because
fundamentally i'm a mean white man
that's a hell of a thing to say in a
debate
god i love that ending there by jordan
right like you don't know anything about
my life but fundamentally i'm a mean
white man like that's what you've
distilled my existence down to i just
want to say one other thing just on the
on the jordan front and by the way i'm
interviewing jordan tomorrow i talked to
him this morning and we're going to do a
little different type of interview than
we normally would it's going to be a
little more push and pull and open
conversation
but when i was on tour with jordan for a
year and a half
i never saw him angry
there were times that he was sort of
upset about something or he would get a
hit piece written whatever but he would
always try to to give the benefit of the
doubt to the writer he would always try
to
de-escalate tensions all of those things
but all dyson
has left is you're a mean white man i
mean really i know you guys know jordan
well enough is he a mean white man and
if he is mean does it have anything to
do with his skin color and has he ever
said he's better than anyone because of
his skin color so i love the way jordan
just calmly and rationally did that
because you somebody seemed mean there
uh but it was not jordan peterson um and
also you know this is what is wrong with
almost everything the people who
racialize i mean i know i say this all
the time but the people who racialize
everything are the ones who are calling
everyone else racist now for this guy
michael eric dyson this has been going
on for years and years he's been on bill
maher all the time i was actually at a
show a couple years ago
sitting in the audience and um he they
did the overtime segment this is after
the show they do like an extra segment
for youtube and i'm gonna slightly
paraphrase what happened here but they
started talking about reparations
and he said that he's not really for
reparations but he said something to the
effect of if you see a young black
brother you should high school kid you
should buy him if you're a white woman
you should buy him a laptop or an ipad
something like that and everyone in the
audience was clapping like seals
like they're just clapping clapping and
i'm watching this woman in front of me
and this was really what i was
still in the wake up phase to what's
going on with the left i'm watching this
woman there's probably 65 year old woman
white woman in front of me clapping and
it's like they clap for it like oh yes
buy a young black kid a computer yes yes
yes then we're good liberals okay
zippity dippity ha ha but it's like lady
of course she didn't do that right but
that's what they do they virtue signal
about everything that lady i assure you
that was sitting in front of me did not
do that anyway he's on
bill maher show all the time and we've
got a little uh recap from bill maher
show this past friday
when michael eric dyson was on the show
again this is from fox news
real-time host bill maher had a tense
exchange about critical race theory in
schools on friday night's show with
guest michael eric dyson a vanderbilt
university professor mark kicked off the
show's panel discussion by addressing
how democrats got their ass kicked in
tuesday's elections particularly in
virginia where the issue of education
dominated the gubernatorial race won by
republican glenn younkin dyson argued
that parents were spooked by crt even
though none of them can define it and
suggested that they were outraged only
because black history was now being
centered in the school curriculum but i
find that a disingenuous argument
because i don't think that's what people
are objecting to the host mar reacted
they are not objecting to black history
being taught they are
other there are other things going on in
the schools like what dyson asked like
separating children based on race mar
responded and describing them as either
oppressed or oppressor i mean there are
children coming home who feel
traumatized by this that's what parents
are objecting to so first off of course
of course of course i want to give
credit where credit is due bill maher is
100 right he is absolutely right you all
know that this stuff is leaking into the
schools the more the media gaslights you
and pretends and tells you that it's not
happening or they'll the randy
weingarten the teachers unit we don't
teach critical race theory but everyone
should know about critical race theory
they lie about absolutely
everything michael eric tyson also it's
just completely disingenuous to say that
people who are objecting to critical
race theory don't know what it's about
we've defined it a bajillion times and
parents are waking up to exactly what it
is but in the most simplest terms as
carol swain one of my guests last week
at natcon said it's actually a white
supremacist idea that white people have
the power over black people more than
anything else and you're gonna say that
everything boils down to race and there
are inherently good and bad people based
on race that's what the old white
supremacists would have said now it's
what the tolerant lefties would say um
so he's he's just
i don't like talking about people in
this regard but this person is promoted
constantly and that's actually why i
want to do this segment because this
brings me to something that i have been
thinking about a lot and you know i'm a
bit frustrated with and i'm trying to
figure out what to do and i would love
your thoughts on this
if you want to drop me a line but bill
maher for years has been putting this
michael eric dyson guy on the show as
like uh you know just he's got his lefty
he's on the show he's a black guy they
talk about race okay fine well it was
obvious that he was ushering in all of
these stupid ideas now bill maher is
against these ideas i didn't watch the
full show on friday but i doubt bill
maher said he was fully happy that
yunkan won like bill maher who's been
railing against these things should be
screaming i'm thrilled that the
republican won right like they were
about to usher in more of these
anti-liberal these illiberal ideas um so
this shows you my frustration with with
the last remaining liberals i would love
to get to a conclusion
with some of this stuff and i know you
bill maher uh producers watch the show
so i'm saying hello to you right now as
always uh this is an interesting
position if if you get all the you you
usher in these ideas right so this is
sort of what what's happened with the
liberals they ushered in all of these
ideas at the universities on these tv
shows culturally and everything else
then it gets to a point where it's like
oh this is too much i mean boys and
girls are a little bit different like
america's not an evil country but you
ushered it all in then you finally say
okay we've got to do something about
this but until you take that final step
and like bill maher should have been
applauding i will gladly correct me
myself if i'm wrong but if at the
beginning of the show he was like this
is the greatest thing ever republicans
got to win here it's a huge pushback
against critical race theory this is an
absolute
seminal moment in the culture war like
some good things are happening i'm
guessing he didn't do that but i would
gladly do a mega culpa on this tomorrow
that these liberals that in essence are
ushering it all in and then at the end
they don't really tell you what to do or
they don't they don't say what they're
honestly what their honest assessment of
things is and i get the counter argument
by the way because i hear people say
this uh but you know they're easing
people into it and everything else but
at some point that becomes also kind of
dangerous right like if you don't get
people to the end conclusion which as i
always say is that you don't have to be
a republican but you certainly can't be
a democrat um
if you don't get people to the
conclusion then you're just playing this
sort of shell game and i'm not sure what
the end outcome of that is i like people
who do that's what i like i like people
who get to the end of the conclusion and
even if it's uncomfortable you know what
i mean like you're going to lose friends
like bill maher you're going to lose
your hollywood friends you really will
but you've got enough money you've got a
big enough house you you've had success
for all these years like
maybe it maybe the flaw is within your
ideology itself anyway i don't mean this
to attack bill maher really again i
think it's a net good basically but i
think you see my point
uh all right let's go a couple locals
comments before we move on uh prisca
says are there preschoolers on twitter
uh and isn't he a bird can't he tweet
without twitter well that's a great
point about tweeting without twitter
that's actually really funny that aren't
are there preschools on twitter right
because big bird is verified on twitter
as if there's any like little kid like
scrolling twitter like oh what did big
bird say today right so that even shows
you the absurdity even more i mean it's
just it's just absolutely endless uh
guys my full interview with dr drew is
up right now you can watch that on
rumble or on blaze tv or on youtube and
we've got a whole bunch of interviews i
did a bunch of mini
interviews at natcon which again was
such a great conference and really
trying to figure out can this alliance
of liberals
old old-school liberals conservatives
libertarians the religious right like
can we all meld into something to stop
the marxist and then hash out our
differences at the end maybe we can
maybe we can't i mean that was that was
the theme of the entire conference like
we're trying to do it but maybe this
can't work we don't know but it's better
than just uh you know just waving the
white flag so i've got interviews with
jack posobi douglas murray christopher
russo jerome harzoni michael knowles liz
wheeler
amari carl swain seth dylan from babylon
b and jack murphy are all up you can get
them wherever you get my videos as
always if you want to play along
reubenreport.locals.com
and i think i think that's it you have
anything to add
no you got anything
nope that's it see you tomorrow
you